ambiance studieuse dans cette salle de
classe un peu particulière nous sommes
au centre de vie sociale aimé césaire à
mantes la jolie
depuis le début de l'année une vingtaine
de femmes viennent plusieurs fois par
semaine perfectionner leur français au
sein de l'école française des femmes
fondée en 2008 par l'institut des hauts
de seine il s'agit du premier
établissement yvelinois vous proposons
du français langue étrangère ce n'est
pas de l'alphabétisation
donc ce sont des femmes qui sont allées
à l'école et qu'ils sont diplômés dans
leur pays d'origine
donc elles ont acquis les automatismes
de l'apprentissage à la différence de
l'alphabétisation ou là les femmes pour
la plupart ne sont pas allés à l'école
l'adhésion est de 15 euros pour une
année scolaire
après un test de niveau les femmes sont
répartis en plusieurs groupes pour un
meilleur apprentissage et doivent
s'engager à suivre minimum quatre heures
de cours par semaine
en fin d'année si elles le souhaitent
elles peuvent passer un diplôme d'état
le delf diplôme d'étude de langue
française
zineb les oubliera ont toutes les deux
un projet professionnel et souhaitait
également mieux s'intégrer quelqu'un qui
arrive à qu'il n'arrive pas à comprendre
certaines choses ben là aussi on est
comme une équipe
j'ai envie d'apprendre et écrirait à
mieux parler sa tigresse tout simplement
et c'est très très bien
au lieu de rester qu'à la maison il faut
faut donner du temps pour soi
émancipation évolution sociale et
professionnelle
voici les valeurs portées par l'institut
des hauts-de-seine qui avait choisi le
château de versailles pour fêter ses dix
années d'existence
au total plus de 2000 femmes issues de
65 nationalités différentes ont pu
bénéficier de ce programme éducatif
unique en france
une idée qui a particulièrement séduit
le département des yvelines
l'idée c'est de pouvoir peut-être aussi
le développer sur d'autres quartiers
prioritaires
au delà de mantes-la-jolie sachant que
sur mantes la jolie c'est aussi un
ancrage sur le mantois
nous c'est la première année des
chéneaux à mantes la jolie
on savait pas qu'il ya autant de monde
comme ça voici la première fois c'est
pourquoi les visites franchement je
trouve ce merveilleux c'est bien fatma
ainsi que les 400 femmes inscrits dans
les différentes structures ont pu
bénéficier d'une visite guidée du
château de versailles
l'année dernière sont pour sonder
apprenantes qui ont passé le diplôme
d'étude de langues françaises l'ont
obtenu